Okay, let's give it another minute for folks to join, then we'll get going.
Alright, I think we've got most people — I see Dana, Tomás, Rachel, Naomi, James. Let's get started.
Can everyone see my screen alright?
Yep, looks good.
Quick agenda: I want to get through the main topic, leave room for questions, and land on clear action items before we drop. Sound good?
We ran the team-assess tool on everything from Q2 — transcripts, chat, PRs, retros, the pulse survey. Overall health came back 2.7 out of 5. I want to be clear this isn't a gotcha; it's a mirror.
Our three lowest dimensions are trust, conflict, and commitment, all at 2.5. The report gives five recommendations. Let's put a name on each one, because a recommendation nobody owns is just a nice sentence.
I'll own the conflict recommendation, because it's squarely about how I run meetings. The report literally cites me holding 56 to 66 percent of the airtime.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Makes sense to me.
Round-robin, async pre-reads, and I'll let the insights tool nudge me when I pass 40 percent.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
How does this interact with community review and the advisory process, if at all?
Agreed, let's capture it.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Good point — let's do that.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Just flagging that this touches the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, so loop me in when it firms up.
That's fair.
How does this interact with the CARE governance framework, if at all?
Let's confirm in the channel.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Just flagging that this touches the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, so loop me in when it firms up.
Okay, I think I follow. So the plan is basically what you just described.
Let's confirm in the channel.
Is there a risk we're solving a problem we don't have yet?
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Yep.
I'll take the trust one with Sarah — blameless incident notes and celebrating pulling the cord early.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Let's confirm in the channel.
And the accountability recommendation is partly mine to fix: I'm the security single point of failure, so I'll onboard a second reviewer this quarter.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the manifest schema and validator.
Yeah, exactly.
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Sure, I can own that.
Right, right.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
How does this interact with community review and the advisory process, if at all?
I'll pair on trust, and I'll own commitment — the written reopening bar so a settled decision like the license question stops coming back three times.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Sure, I can own that.
Yeah, that's consistent with what we talked about in the last sync.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Let's confirm in the channel.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
Agreed, let's capture it.
Sure, I can own that.
Let's not rathole on this — can we take the fine detail offline?
Mm, let me sit with that one.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync anyway.
How does this interact with the security review pipeline, if at all?
Yeah, exactly.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Good — as long as it's reversible, I'm comfortable moving.
Sure, I can own that.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
That matches what I was seeing on my end with the access needs-board and credits broker.
I'd rather over-communicate here — can we write down who's doing what?
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
That's fair.
Okay, works for me.
Agreed, let's capture it.
I don't feel strongly on this one — I'll defer to whoever owns it.
That's fair.
Sorry, can you go back to the point about the review pass?
Hmm, okay.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Makes sense to me.
Good point — let's do that.
Alright, moving on.
Dana and I will take results — outcome over optics. Q4 fundraiser is coming and that's exactly when the optics pressure spikes, so we'll watch each other on it.
Sure.
Just flagging that this touches the access needs-board and credits broker, so loop me in when it firms up.
Right, and that lines up with the constraint we set at kickoff.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Agreed, let's capture it.
That's fair.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Let's confirm in the channel.
On the conflict one — I want the format to include async pre-reads, not just round-robin.
Do we actually need a decision on this today, or can it wait a week?
I contribute better having read ahead, and the report flagged that I was scored near zero in meetings while being the top chat contributor. I'll help design the format.
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Good point — let's do that.
Can someone capture that in the notes close to verbatim?
Sure, I can own that.
How does this interact with the access needs-board and credits broker, if at all?
I'm a little worried about the timeline, but I'm not blocking on it.
Let me play that back to make sure we're all aligned on it.
That's fair.
Can we make sure that lands as an action item so it doesn't get lost?
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the security review pipeline anyway.
Mm, let me sit with that one.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync anyway.
Agreed, let's capture it.
I'll take that one — it's adjacent to community review and the advisory process anyway.
One caution before we run off and implement. Let's make sure we're changing behavior, not gaming a number. The report is a mirror, not the goal. If we optimize the score we've missed the point.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Right, that's what I meant.
How does this interact with the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync, if at all?
Mm-hm.
Agreed, and that's the frame I want to keep. Owners are assigned. We run a fresh assessment at the end of Q3 and see whether the behaviors actually moved.
One concern and then I'll drop it: are we sure about the sequencing here?
Just flagging that this touches community review and the advisory process, so loop me in when it firms up.
Sure, I can own that.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
Agreed, let's capture it.
What would it take to de-risk that a little?
Okay, works for me.
Right.
Let me pull up the numbers so we're not going off memory.
Right, that's what I meant.
Can we double-check that against what we agreed last week?
I want to make sure I understand the tradeoff before we commit to anything.
That's fair. I'll withdraw the concern.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay — any questions before we wrap?
Should I loop anyone else in on the the security review pipeline side, or is that covered?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Should I loop anyone else in on the community review and the advisory process side, or is that covered?
Should I loop anyone else in on the the access needs-board and credits broker side, or is that covered?
Good question — let's confirm the specifics in the channel so we don't rathole here.
Alright, let me read back the action items so we're aligned before we drop.
Sarah has the follow-up on the CARE governance framework — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Dana has the follow-up on the roadmap and keeping the two tracks in sync — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Tomás has the follow-up on the security review pipeline — I'll capture the specifics in the notes.
Great. I'll write it all up and drop it in the channel. Thanks everyone.